[Music]
[Applause]
Albert Breer the Monday Morning
Quarterback never has to defend himself
he's always right and he joins us right
now Albert thanks for joining us uh let
me start with the poll question Seton
coughed that up for uh for Albert yeah
Dan who had the worst weekend we have uh
Alabama we have uh the Giants and we
have the Bengals
out of those and USA Basketball
threw them in I was gonna I was gonna
ask
we lost to Canada and Germany
we lost to Canada and basketball think
of the bronze medal game yeah and bro no
Canada's has a really talented team
there's a lot of guys in the NBA who are
from Canada that you might not realize
okay yeah okay do we like but we sent
over like our C team or something Albert
stay in your lane here
stay in your lane
um I would say that the the the one that
would to me of like the three I think
you mentioned the Giants the Bengals in
Alabama I think the Giants is the
toughest loss just because I I think the
Bengals and the Bengals is easy to couch
it where it's at like all right this hat
this is a result in some way ways of a
really sloppy track in Cleveland bad
conditions Joe burrow not having a lot
of practice time or work with his
receivers the Bengals are going to work
it out
Alabama's probably going to work it out
too right like now are they going to be
back in the national title game maybe
maybe not but their season's not down
the drain
the Giants you got to ask a lot of
questions about you know what happened
there and you know obviously the great
year last year but a lot of things went
right for them last year and it was
almost like the it's almost like the the
the the bill can't do on that all at
once I mean I I it was almost like I had
to re-remember looking at the box score
the Cowboys first touchdown
was there 26th point of the game
their first offensive touchdown was
their 26th point of the game which is
wild to think about
um so yeah I mean I think the Giants are
probably the team of those three that's
doing the most soul-searching I would
say which puts you in the position to
answer that question yeah we tend to
look at the negative like that team got
blown out the Bengals got blown out the
Giants got blown out uh and and we don't
focus on the team that you know did the
blowing out Dallas how much credit do
you give them without overreacting to
them how much credit do you give the
Cleveland Browns without overreacting to
it
yeah I think Cleveland's interesting
because of the new coordinator and I
think this is maybe one of those story
lines that we didn't talk about a lot
about
um you know back when Jim Schwartz was
hired in January February whatever it
was but windup might wind up really
impacting the NFL season because I think
they have horses on that side of the
ball you know obviously miles Garrett's
one of the best players in the sport
their secondary played incredible
yesterday and they've got players back
there like you know a couple of first
round picks and Denzel Ward and Greg
Newsom
um and I think we believe their offense
can be pretty good you know like if
DeSean Watson gets back close to what he
was a few years ago their offensive
Line's really good they had a bad injury
yesterday in losing Conklin but they've
got a young kid in dwan Jones they like
in that spot Nick chubb's been one of
the best backs in football
um if that defense comes around now all
of a sudden they're pretty complete you
know and Jim Schwartz is a guy who 20
years ago was the Boy Wonder defensive
coordinator of the Titans was the
defense coordinator more recently of a
Super Bowl champion Eagles team he's a
really sharp coach and you know we all
talked a lot about Vic fangio getting
hired in Miami and rightfully so like
Vic's you know Vic made an impact
yesterday and and getting Jalen Phillips
free to to to get the sack to close the
Chargers out
um Jim Schwartz is pretty damn
accomplished too so that's sort of what
I take out of that one is like if you're
looking at the Browns and you want to
say maybe the arrows pointing up here is
that they have been pretty competitive
over Kevin spaceki's first three years
and they've done it without being very
good on defense and so if Jim Schwartz
can get a really good group of players
playing to the level they should be
playing at maybe the Browns are more of
a threat and what could be the strongest
division in football than you thought
more surprising that the LA Rams go to
Seattle and win or the Chargers at home
against the Dolphins and they lose
can we do can the can I say can I debunk
the dumbest storyline of the off season
right here I love a good debunking
absolutely
the idiots who thought that the Rams
were tanking for Caleb Williams
I like I hope they watched every single
minute of this
because with that coach and that
quarterback if you thought the Rams were
tanking if you thought Sean McVeigh came
back to throw a season
to get Caleb Williams
you have no clue who or what you're
looking at
um is what the Rams did sustainable I
don't know
um you know like they have they're
carrying 19 rookies on their 53-man
roster they're carrying 75 million
dollars in dead money the depth thing's
probably going to catch up with them
eventually right like but
you know I think one thing we've seen
over the last you know five years is six
years now is that Sean mcvay's teams are
going to be a to deal with on a
weekend week out basis and you're going
to be dealing with a lot schematically
on offense they're going to be
aggressive on defense uh the schemes are
always going to be top-notch and you're
going to get really good quarterback
play and I I can tell you talking to
Matthew Stafford over the summer
like he was as happy and upbeat as I've
seen him in a while because he's healthy
again
and so
um you know I I I think the Rams are
going to be a tough out on a
week-to-week basis again like they
they've got some roster issues they're
going to have to work through but this
idea that they were throwing the season
was so freaking stupid from the start
and I think McVeigh at the very least
has them
competing at 500 through the end of the
year and maybe we're looking at the end
of the year and they've got a bunch of
young players who are on the way up and
they've got now a first round pick for
the first time in almost a decade and a
clean cap going into 2024.
the Chargers
I don't know man like I just
they just
it's I I try not to be surprised anymore
I guess the best way to answer that
question you know because they do have
talent and they do have potential and I
thought Kellen Moore was going to make a
difference and I think Justin Herbert
looked pretty good on balance
I it's just like for the last 15 years
doesn't matter who the coach is doesn't
matter who the quarterback is they've
like perpetually been next year's team
you know and I don't know what it is but
you always get to these moments and it's
like all right here's where they get
over the hump and for one reason or
another they just haven't been able to
do it and so
um look like I I still think it's a
playoff caliber team the Dolphins are
really talented and explosive on offense
and they add fangio on defense
um but I I think it's it's hard not to
look at the Chargers and think is this
what we've been looking at over the last
15 years and maybe that's not fair to
Brandon Staley and Justin Herbert
because they've only been there for a
few of those 15 years but it's just a
weird thing it just feels like the same
story again he's the Monday Morning
Quarterback Albert Breer joining us on
the program the Eagles were
disappointing to me they started out
16-0 and then you let the Patriots come
back Patriots could have won that game
um I don't know how you feel about the
pay Patriots in a loss or how you feel
about the Eagles in a win
yeah I I think I would agree the Eagles
were a little disappointing
um you know I and I think that this is
Maria what all coaches will tell you is
week one is you know often an anomaly
and it's really hard to take much from
week one because there's so many
unscattered looks across the league and
there's so much the coaches are doing
and there's so much of a guessing game
going on
and like the one thing I can sort of the
one thing I sort of think with the
Eagles out coming out of yesterday
they had such a good mix on their
coaching staff the last two years with
Nick sirianni's group and I remember
hearing all these stories about like how
they were all you know they're all the
same age and they all have kids the same
age and they all work at the same pace
and there was even this great story and
I don't know if you know you read this
but I wrote this after the last regular
season game for them last year so Nick
siriani comes from like a long line of
high school football coaches and you
know how high school football coaches
will go and you know have beers on
Friday nights after the game and
someone's backyard right
Nick siriani actually did that with his
coaching staff last year after the
regular season because it was like well
I never got the chance to do this we
can't do that in the NFL so now we have
the buy so we're gonna go and do it now
it's just sort of indicative of the mix
they had there
and so you do Wonder like they lost both
their coordinators and I'm not saying
Brian Brian Johnson and Sean Desai
aren't going to be good offensive and
defensive coordinators they're really
smart young coaches
but the mix was changed a little bit you
know so you wonder if in week one
they're still working through some of
that and um that's the question I would
have I I felt like coming in the
Patriots would have a chance to have a
top five defense I think you saw that
really encouraging what you thought from
their first round pick and Christian
Gonzalez and that the plan for them was
to lean on their defense and their run
game in short games and you know Bill
Belichick may be dusting off the Super
Bowl 25 game plan you know and like how
to how to run the team this year I'd be
really encouraged what I saw from them
playing from behind it looks like Bill
O'Brien made a difference they were
creative they played with Pace early in
the game
um they flattened out a little bit then
they adjusted which I think was a good
sign versus where they were a year ago
and Mac Jones played really well you
know so I think you have an established
formula in what they're going to be in
New England which I think would get them
to the middle of the AFC leaning on the
Run game and defense then yesterday you
got a chance to see them play from
behind and lean on their quarterback and
I think you saw some good things in that
into always great to talk to you thank
you Albert all right thanks Dan that's
Albert Breer he is the Monday Morning
Quarterback